[Music]
what we need to realize is the planet is
actually alive
the planet is minded our presence here
is the tip-off to the fact that some
kind of extraordinarily transitory phase
changing dynamic is underway at the
frontier of the informational becoming
that constitutes the highest level of
organization on this planet that's what
history is it's an organizational frenzy
and an effort to do something and it has
a life of its own we are acting within
it but we are also like iron filings in
a three-dimensional environment to the
degree that we can align ourselves with
what is wanting to happen we can
participate in it and replicate the mean
with clarity the mean can be miss
replicated it's just like a genetic
message it can be miss copy so what is
important is a certain relationship to
community a certain clarity of mind a
certain realism not despair but
awareness
the context of the situation and in
global II the context of the situation
is about a hundred and twenty minutes
sent into the abyss as far as I can tell
it's tight in here we're navigating on
the very narrow passage where the stakes
rise exponentially we have the ability
to do almost anything therefore we can
summon from ourselves whatever nation
capable low and
[Music]
it seems to me that the best patients
come from the forbidden side of reality
if we're willing to live within the
dominator geography of what is correct
consciousness and what is forbidden
conscious so we're in the middle of a
civil rights dilemma a problem here that
touches on the fundamentals of human
freedom right of religious
self-expression
rights of privacy so forth and so on
it touches at the core of the human
experience what is being fought over is
how weird people shall be allowed to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I think people should be as weird as
they possibly can be it seems the only
reasonable stance to take
if we're not as weird as we possibly can
be then we're probably buying into
somebody else's cultural game
you